on
bonjour à tous dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre les questions
cribles consacré à la montagne
développement économique aménagement du
territoire problématique foncière
les sénateurs vont passer au crible une
thématique
c'est donc cet après midi la montagne la
montagne qui pour laquelle cécile duflot
la ministre de l'aménagement du
territoire et du logement
munis de l'égalité des territoires qui
répondra aux questions
dessinateur c'est pierre jarlier pour le
groupe i des u c'est qui doit être le
premier à prendre la parole tout de
suite direction licenciés reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
cribles thématiques sur la montagne
aménagement du territoire problématique
foncière développement économique par
des pauses et madame cécile duflot
ministre de l'égalité des territoires et
du logement je rappelle que l'auteur ou
la ministre pour sa réponse dispose de
chacun de deux minutes une réplique
d'une durée d'une minute au maximum peut
être présenté par l'auteur de la
question où l'un des membres de son
groupe politique je vous demande de
respecter cette durée dans le temps de
parole pour la première question la
parole est à monsieur pierre jarlier
pour le groupe
udi merci monsieur le président madame
ministre mes chers collègues les
territoires de montagne sont soumis à
des handicaps spécifiques qui
nécessitent des réponses adaptées des
pouvoirs publics nous avons souvent
rappeler ici avec mes collègues
montagnards notamment avec jean paul
amoudry avec lequel je partage ce propos
l'europe et l'état ont reconnu ces
difficultés en matière agricole en
ouvrant la voie à une meilleure prise en
compte des spécificités de notre
agriculture de montagne dans la nouvelle
politique agricole commune mais elle a
ses particularités s'ajoutent parfois un
certain isolement
une faible densité démographique et des
contraintes géographiques géographiques
et climatiques qui rendent plus
difficile la vie quotidienne
cette situation est particulièrement
vrai en moyenne montagne qui subit une
réelle mutation sociale il ya une paire
très importantes d'actifs agricoles qui
constituait pourtant le souk de son
économie locale
alors il faut bien reconnaître que les
collectivités de montagne sont souvent
frotter à un manque de moyens pour
surmonter à la fois à ces mutations et
c'est à ces handicaps naturels
d'autant que les contraintes qui pèsent
sur elle en matière d'urbanisme
notamment sont de plus en plus lourde si
les territoires de montagne constitue le
socle incontournable pour la
préservation des grands équilibres
écologiques de notre pays il faut aussi
veiller à un juste équilibre entre la
protection de la montagne et son
développement indispensable même un
jugement équitable durable du territoire
c'est le sens de la montagne de 1985
fondatrice d'une politique nationale de
la montagne bientôt trente ans plus tard
le contexte économique institutionnel et
social de ces territoires a changé et
cette loi mérite d'être maintenant
revisiter les nouvelles opportunités de
développement ne manquent pas le
désenclavement numérique le télétravail
la pluriactivité les filières de qualité
ou encore le maillage des services de
proximité pour ne citer que ces exemples
je pense aussi à la transition
énergétique
de leur côté les collectivités organise
la solidarité locale en développant
l'intercommunalité autour de projets de
territoire et pour parvenir à surmonter
leurs difficultés elles ont aussi besoin
de la sonorité nationale or madame la
ministre vous avez annoncé un prochain
projet de loi sur l'égalité des
territoires
un chapitre consacré la montagne israël
trouvera t-il sa place et comment
comptez vous associer les forces vives
de la montagne dans la concertation
préalable merci pour vous répondre modem
cécile duflot monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur jarvi vous avez
raison les territoires de montagne
subissent des contraintes fortes et vous
l'avez compris à l'occasion de nombreux
débats ici ma vision de l'égalité des
territoires
c'est bien entendu de faire en sorte que
chaque territoire soit pris en compte de
façon différenciée l'égalité n'est pas
l'uniformité c'est une évidence et c'est
tout l'esprit qui anime la stratégie que
je porte et la création du commissariat
général à l'égalité des territoires
c'est aussi tout l'esprit de la loi
montagne vous l'avez évoqué dont nous
allons bientôt fêter le trentième
anniversaire
j'ai par ailleurs pleinement conscience
des contraintes particulières qui pèsent
sur les territoires de montagne qui pèse
parfois sur leur développement et vous
le savez notamment à l'occasion du débat
sur la loi allure nous avons intégré un
certain nombre de ces problématiques
dans le cadre des
dispositions législatives pour s'adapter
au plus près des réalités et des besoins
des territoires de montagne mais je
crois pouvoir vous dire que le
gouvernement a bien compris dans sa
globalité
l'enjeu des territoires de montagne et
un effort de péréquation important ainsi
été fait en 2013 vis-à-vis des
territoires les plus fragiles
je tiens à souligner notamment la
disposition qui a permis de
comptabiliser pour les autres
montagnarde le double de kilomètres de
route qu'ils ont à leur charge pour
déterminer leur dotation est né ainsi
qu'en des difficultés d'entretien de ses
infrastructures
pour ce qui est du très haut débit il y
a également la spécifie la prise en
compte de la spécificité du rural et de
la montagne
nous travaillons également dans le cadre
des dispositions du titre égalité des
territoires de la loi de mobilisation
des régions pour la croissance et
l'emploi et promotion de l'égalité des
territoires mais il n'est aujourd'hui
pas prévu une remise en cause de la loi
montagne dans ce qu'elle avait
d'essentiel pour ces territoires c'est à
dire de leur consacrer 7 spécifique leur
spécificité en revanche et je le redis
dans le cadre de la loi allure un
certain nombre de préoccupations sont
prises en compte
néanmoins par ailleurs il y un sujet qui
est un sujet absolument essentiel qui
est celui des de l'accès aux services au
public
et là je peux vous indiquer monsieur le
sénateur que d'ici 2017
je souhaite que l'état puisse participer
de façon pérenne un réseau de neil
points d'accès aux services publics
maison de service public dans une eau
une expérimentation est née au sein de
du dispositif plus de services au plié
au public
ce réseau sera fondée sur l'initiative
locale ce qui permet là encore une
adaptation maximale à la typologie des
territoires en montagne il ya peut-être
des opérateurs qu'on ne trouve pas dans
d'autres territoires et qui auront toute
leur place dans ces maisons de service
public je pense que nous pouvons aussi
travailler ensemble si nécessaire à
d'autres dispositions qui pourraient
être incluses dans le projet de loi qui
serait de nature à répondre à d'autres
enjeux des territoires ruraux de manière
générale et de la montagne en
particulier
j'ai ainsi indiqué que je souhaitais sur
le schéma d'accès aux services publics
pouvoir travailler avec les conseils
généraux qui seraient volontaires avant
même l'adoption cette loi dans un cadre
à la fois expérimental et qui
permettrait de nourrir le travail
législatif je souhaite
des départements de montagne s'il le
souhaite même également puissent se
joindre à cette disposition par ailleurs
je suis très attentif vous le savez aux
travaux du conseil national de la
montagne et je ne verrais que des
avantages à ce qu'il puisse y avoir des
réflexions en vue de la préparation du
titre égalité des territoires dans cette
instance
tu peux ainsi vous indiquer que la datar
et à votre disposition pour travailler à
ces propositions
merci au ministre à la parole est à
présent à pierre jarlier pas présent à
nouveau pour le restic merci monsieur et
madame et liste merci pour ces propos je
pense que les montagnards seront
sensibles a effectivement ce que vous
reconnaissiez que l'égalité ne veut pas
dire uniformité reprenant vos propos je
crois qu'à des situations inégales il
faut aussi trouver des situations des
solutions différenciées
c'était le but de cette loi montagne qui
mérite sans doute d'être revisitée mais
comme vous l'avez dit sans fondement
doit être maintenu je crois qu'on a deux
noms des bas effectivement dans la loi
allure déjà un certain nombre d'avancées
ont été opérées il y a encore à faire
parce qu'il ne faut pas évidemment
sanctuariser les territoires ruraux
notamment en montagne
s'agissant des dotations et bien là
aussi il ya eu des avancées dans la loi
de finances 2014 mais nous devrons mieux
prendre en compte les charges
territoriales auxquelles on va faire
face les collectivités dans la dgf je
crois qu'il ya une réflexion qui est en
cours madame la ministre qui a assisté
au congrès de l'amm de la montagne s'y
est engagé et nous espérons donc on
comprendra mieux en compte les charges
territoriales dans le calcul de la dgf à
l'avenir et enfin s'agissant des
services publics je crois qu'on voit
avec satisfaction vous avez une volonté
de mailler le territoire avec des
maisons de service tout ça reste à faire
parce qu'il ya une vraie il ya une vraie
aujourd'hui une vraie inquiétude sur les
territoires ruraux
merci la parole le dr andré vue reto
pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
l'accroissement du phénomène dit des
lits froids et des volets clos est une
évolution préoccupante pour le devenir
des stations de montagne
on estime aujourd'hui qu'entre 20 et 40
% du parc est obsolète
en terme de surface et d'équipements
cette sous-occupation chronique des
meublés de tourisme entraîne une perte
d'activité économique pour les
territoires concernés
une rénovation de l'immobilier de
loisirs en montagne aurait pourtant des
incidences multiples elle est la
condition de la pérennité de
l'attractivité des stations de montage
elle permettra d'éviter la fuite en
avant immobilière au détriment des
espaces naturels et la constitution de
véritables friches urbaines
elle constitue une source de travaux non
délocalisables pour les entreprises elle
permettra grâce à la remise à niveau
thermique des bâtiments de lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique
elle apportera enfin une réponse aux
attentes nouvelles de la clientèle
pourtant le constat est malheureusement
aujourd'hui unanimes les outils mis en
place depuis la loi sru en 2000 jusqu'au
rapport de la ce est n'ont pas permis de
même manière que les expérimentations
sur le territoire une des résultats les
résultats escomptés
une impulsion nouvelle donc aujourd'hui
nécessaire le 18 juillet madame la
ministre du tourisme a instauré un
groupe montagne afin de travailler sur
les deux plans latics suivante la
diversification de l'offre en montagne
et les habitations de levier de loisirs
composé de professionnels et d'élus de
la montagne là notamment pour objectif
de proposer des mesures concrètes
permettant la remise sur le marché des
biens immobiliers dits froids par
ailleurs un groupe de travail composé de
l'anem et des autres associations d'élus
des communes touristiques à formuler des
propositions création d'un observatoire
de l'immobilier en montagne association
de l'anru au groupe de travail montagne
pour pouvoir s'inspirer des dispositifs
qui est la rénovation urbaine aux trois
propriétaires réalisant des travaux de
réhabilitation des mêmes avantages
financiers et fiscaux que ceux utilisés
pour les constructions neuves
enfin certains opérateurs ont récemment
mise en place de ce site et foncières le
très gros fichiers nous indiqué madame
la ministre
quelles sont les premières conclusions
du groupe de travail du ministère et le
calendrier de mise en oeuvre des
nouveaux dispositifs d'incitation à la
rénovation du mobilier de de loisirs
merci la parole à madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur vers eto'o le
problème de la dégradation l'immobilier
loisirs et délits et le des lits froids
comme vous venez de l'indiquer est en
grande partie lié au concept de
résidences de tourisme avec un concept
basé sur la dissociation entre
propriétaires des murs et exploitants
qui sont liés par un contrat
d'obligation de mise en location pour
une période relativement courte
cela génère la sortie d'une partie des
délits du marché locatif à la fin des
contrats et un déficit d'investissement
dans les murs qui entraîne souvent une
déqualification locative du bien pour
faire face à la dégradation du parc les
stations s'engage ont parfois dans la
production de nouveaux lits ce qui a des
conséquences problème
atik en matière économique et
environnemental et qui renforce
l'impression de perdre en qualité du
parc existant et parfois vous l'avait
indiqué la création de friches en
augmentant la consommation de foncier
il semble donc indispensable d'agir plus
fortement dans la réhabilitation du parc
existant
comme vous venez de le souligner je
partage votre avis nous sommes toutefois
confronté pour inciter les propriétaires
à réhabiliter leurs biens plusieurs
difficultés
d'une part la propriété de ces
résidences et souvent très morcelé par
ailleurs les dispositifs fiscaux tendent
il est vrai aujourd'hui à favoriser la
construction neuve enfin les coûts de
fonctionnement de ces résidences sont
souvent importants et limite de fait la
capacité d'investissement des pour des
propriétaires les outils existants comme
les autres il les opérations de
réhabilitation l'immobilier loisirs et
les villages résidentiels de tourisme
n'ont pas permis
il est vrai la mort c'est un
réinvestissement massif dans ses
résidences en revanche il existe un
outil de la loi montagne le dispositif
de convention d'aménagement touristique
qui pourrait représenter une réelle
opportunité pour la problématique des
lits froids il oblige l'ensemble des
opérateurs à s'engager contractuellement
avec la commune sur le respect des
termes de la convention obligations en
matière de maintien sur le marché des
lits marchands peuvent des obligations
peuvent ainsi de ce type peuvent être
théoriquement inscrits il a pourtant
était peu utilisé
une étude a donc été engagée à
l'initiative du groupe de travail sa
voix à ce sujet qui réunit acteurs
locaux et services déconcentrés de
l'état
par ailleurs des initiatives
intéressantes se sont développés en
particulier celle de la création de la
réserve de la foncière rénovation
montagne au printemps 2013
ma collègue sylvia pinel a monté un
groupe de travail ad hoc sur le sujet et
nous continuons de travailler notamment
sur le cadre fiscal dont on pourrait
imaginer qu'il soit là aussi rénové
merci mon cher collègue si vous remercie
madame la ministre de de votre réponse
partageant à la fois les constats et
effectivement les difficultés
rencontrées dans la mise en place
d'opérations de réhabilitation du mobile
loisirs je veux insister sur la
nécessité de lever des obstacles
juridiques réglementaires législatif qui
aujourd'hui en empêche les les acteurs
locaux qui sont très mobilisés sur cette
problématique
on dit sur l'attractivité des stations
effectivement de ne pas remettre en eau
des opérations donc la nécessité
d'avancer rapidement sur des dispositifs
concrets merci très bien merci la parole
est à présent à madame la présidente
annie david
pour le groupe ce rssi oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues l'isère est composé de
grandes zones urbaines à vocation
métropolitaine mais aussi de grandes
massif aussi divers que son l'oisans la
chartreuse belledonne le vercors le
trièves en tant que sénatrice du
département je porte avec les élus et
des acteurs de ce territoire l'ambition
de son développement équilibré solidaire
des sommets vers la plaine et
réciproquement
néanmoins j'entends leurs inquiétudes au
fil des débats autour de la loi de
décentralisation et du projet allure
devant la concentration des pouvoirs
dans des unités urbaines toujours plus
vaste le désengagement de l'état le
risque d' inégalité entre les
territoires et d'effacement des
particularités rurales et celles
spécifiques des montagnes j'entends
aussi l'inquiétude des regroupements de
professionnels de la montagne devant la
logique de compétitivité dans laquelle
l'économie agricole et artisanale de la
montagne ne pèsera pas lourd 1 la
montagne n'est pas seulement un espace
récréatif ou une réserve énergétique
elle attend une politique de solidarité
amont aval et de développement
économiques a visé humaine impulsée par
l'état vous mettez en place une nouvelle
organisation de l'action publique pour
les terrils et territoires pardon avec
la création du commissariat général pour
l'égalité des territoires
mais au delà des urgences que l'on
connaît tous couverture en très haut
débit et téléphonie mobile la
réglementation en matière d'urbanisme ou
encore protection des salariés
saisonniers les acteurs de la montagne
attentes de ce commissariat l'ingénierie
et les moyens financiers indispensables
montage de projets structurants en
matière de développement économique
prenant en compte les spécificités et
les capacités de nos montagnes dans une
logique de massifs que seul l'état peut
porter le risque de prédominance de
l'urbain sur le rural et grands au sein
du nouveau commissariat général tout
comme dans les conférences territoriales
issu de la loi de l'affirmation des
métropoles où la représentation de la
montagne sera faible
aussi madame la ministre je vous demande
d'indiquer quels objectifs vous assigner
au commissariat général pour l'égalité
des territoires et quels moyens
financiers vous comptez mettre
concrètement à disposition de nos
territoires
madame la ministre madame la sénatrice
david je crois beaucoup aux vertus du
nouvel outil que le sera le commissariat
général à l'égalité des territoires et
je vais et je veux vous rassurer tout à
fait il n'est absolument pas question au
contraire même sans doute d'amoindrir
l'action de l'état à destination des
territoires ruraux ip ruraux ou
d'abandonner les dispositifs qui les
concernent mais bien à renouveler cette
politique et a réaffirmé la nécessité
d'une solidarité entre tous les
territoires de la république et c'est
dans cette nouvelle relation entre
l'état et les collectivités locales que
la mise en oeuvre du cgt se fera vous
connaissez son calendrier la nouvelle
structure devrait être sur pied à
l'horizon de la fin du premier trimestre
2014 la mission de préfiguration piloté
par éric delzant et raphaël le méhauté
est en cours ce sera donc une ambition
nouvelle transversale et
fondamentalement respectueuse de la
diversité des territoires sans les
opposer qui sera au coeur de l'action du
cgiet
il sera d'ailleurs particulièrement
attentifs à ces territoires
on le sait depuis ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
parliez de la question des métropoles
elles se sont dotées elles mêmes de
leurs propres capacités d'ingénierie
tout le rôle du cgiet sera donc de bien
accompagner l'articulation entre les
différentes politiques et d'apporter une
attention particulière au territoire
meurtri ou dans une situation plus
difficile que sont par exemple les
territoires de la politique de la ville
d'où le regroupement de l'ensemble des
structures sg steve et accès au sein de
feu ce futur commissariat général mais
le budget 2014 montre bien d'ores et
déjà l'action en faveur des territoires
ruraux puisque ne s'agit pas seulement
de structure mais bien d'actions
concrètes en assurant les engagements
pris par l'état dans le financement des
pôles d'excellence rurale en
accompagnement le développement des
pôles territoriaux de coopération
économique qui seront de véritables
outils de rhodes de dynamisation des
territoires par l'économie sociale et
solidaire et enfin de conserver
l'enveloppent de la prime à
l'aménagement du territoire à hauteur de
40 millions d'euros pour soutenir des
projets
cette création ou d'extension
d'entreprises vous le voyez la
mobilisation du gouvernement à l'égard
des territoires est très importante et
elle le sera encore plus avec ce nouvel
outil qui en décloisonnant les pratiques
pour à réinventer le lien entre l'état
et les territoires notamment les
territoires de montagne où les
territoires hyper euros merci madame la
présidente
merci monsieur le président merci madame
la ministre de cette réponse et j'ai eu
plaisir également à entendre comme tout
à l'heure à monsieur jarlier le disait
que vous dites égalité ne veut pas dire
uniformité en effet pour la montagne ça
a beaucoup de sens
je pense notamment aux débats que nous
avons eus lors du dernier congrès sur
l'application des normes et en effet
égalité ne veut pas dire uniformité vous
nous avez dit également vouloir
réaffirmer la solidarité de l'état
envers nos territoires de montagne je ne
peux que m'en satisfaire vous nous
parler du budget et moi je n'ai pas tout
à fait la même lecture que la vôtre est
sans doute n'était elle pas suffisamment
global mais j'ai vu dans la mission
politique des territoires une diminution
du budget de l'état donc cela
m'inquiétait cela m'inquiète car bien
sûr ce nouveau commissariat général à
l'égalité des territoires devra répondre
à toutes ces toutes les attentes de nos
territoires de montagne mais sont ces
jeux objectif pardon seront élargis et
les finances qui lui sont alloués seront
diminués donc je garde quand même un peu
d'inquiétude tout en ayant entendu et
apprécier la réponse que vous m'avez
fait madame la ministre a très bien la
parole à ronan dantec pour le groupe
écologiste
oui monsieur le président madame le
ministre qui si on reviendra donc en
complément de celle d'andré vers eto'o
le modèle français de développement
touristique s'appuie depuis toujours sur
la construction de nouveaux lits
touristiques pour financer la création
des équipements dédiés au tourisme des
lits touristiques seront créés chaque
année grâce à des dispositifs de
défiscalisation avantageux j'y
reviendrai tandis qu en parlait d'autres
sortent du marché ne sont plus mis en
location
dans certains cas les chiffres sont
édifiants pour prendre l'exemple de la
tarentaise 5000 y créer d'un côté et
autant sortis du marché chaque année
tandis que moins de 50% des lits
touristiques sont ouverts en pleine
saison
ce phénomène donc des lits froids et des
volets clos autrement dit la
sous-occupation chronique des meublés de
tourisme constaté en montagne entraîne
des conséquences dommageables pour les
territoires je crois que le fait que
nous soyons 2 à poser des questions
proche souligne l'importance de cette
question
ce système est économiquement aberrant
il favorise l'artificialisation et
l'étalement ainsi que la pression à la
fois sur le foncier sur la ressource en
eau et en énergie
il accroît enfin les difficultés de
logement ces constructions en effet
favorisé une spéculation immobilière sur
ces territoires qui aboutit à chasser
les populations locales des zones
touristiques c'est une question
importante et notamment les actifs et
les saisonniers qui n'ont pas les moyens
de se loger sur les sites
face à ces constats la ministre du
tourisme vous l'avez dit madame la
ministre a annoncé la création d'un
groupe de travail sur le sujet et le
lancement d'un plan de réhabilitation de
l'immobilier de loisirs une évaluation
est en cours mais je veux rappeler ici
l'urgence de cette situation nous avons
affaire à un problème d'aménagement des
territoires dont la résorption doit
s'inscrire dans une réponse globale
commencé par faire un état des lieux
précis des entrées sorties du marché des
hébergements touristiques évaluer les
dispositifs de défiscalisation notamment
adhérèrent zone de revitalisation rurale
et censi bouvard qui d'ailleurs va faire
l'objet d'une évaluation suite un
amendement écologistes sur le projet de
loi allure plusieurs questions donc
madame la ministre
autour de cette spéculation comment
faire en sorte que les hébergements
touristiques existants perdure au lieu
de fermer
comment réorganiser la rénovation de
l'ancien et permettre aux actifs de se
loger et surtout n'y at il pas lieu
enfin compte tenu de l'urgence de
stopper la défiscalisation sur le neuf
et de reporter ces sommes sur la
rénovation de l'existant sur merci de
vos réponses madame la minière sylvain
d'un ami ni souple
oui monsieur dantec je vais donc
complété par ma réponse ce que j'ai
répondu à monsieur vers eto'o tout à
l'heure mais je note que le fait que
vous posiez tous les deux cette question
montre bien l'importance de cette
question
vous avez raison de souligner
l'importance du foncier en montagne et
les faits de dégradation plus importante
du parc existant du fait de
l'attractivité du parc neuf donc la
difficulté se renforce au fil de l'eau
fil des années et je le dis la
réhabilitation de l'existant nous aurons
les mêmes difficultés qu'aujourd'hui
avec les résidences en cours de
construction si nous ne l'a sûrement pas
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que cette
dégradation risque par un phénomène de
cavalerie de se reproduire donc c'est
bien sûr la réhabilitation comme je les
dis à la rénovation énergétique des
résidences ancienne qu'il nous faut agir
en priorité je le redis le conseil
national de la montagne
il travaillait dans certains territoires
des groupes de travail associant élus
représentants de l'état se sont aussi
constitués pour mettre en oeuvre des
solutions pragmatiques et adaptés aux
spécificités de chaque territoire je
pense en particulier aux groupes de
travail sa voix que vous connaissez sans
doute nous pouvons aussi mieux utiliser
les outils à notre disposition bientôt à
notre disposition
je voudrais en profiter pour souligner
un point que je n'ai pas indiqué tout à
l'heure c'est que les règles de vote sur
les travaux dans les copropriétés
modifié par la loi allure vont être de
nature à faciliter la prise de décision
dans ses résidences où la propriété est
morcelé et nous verrons ensemble
l'efficacité que cela peut produire je
pense aussi à une meilleure utilisation
des conventions d'aménagement
touristique qui sont prévus dans la loi
montagne que j'ai évoqués et qui
permettent à la commune d'exiger un
engagement de la part de l'opérateur sur
le niveau de mise en marché des lits
cette possibilité est aujourd'hui peu
utilisé mais je souhaite que nous
travaillons pour la rendre plus
praticable pour les communes il nous
faut par ailleurs réfléchir aux
dispositions à même de renforcer
l'investissement dans ces résidences la
foncière rénovation montagne monté début
2013 en est un exemple intéressant elle
pourra permettre aussi d'ouvrir l'art et
la réflexion sur les questions fiscales
puisque c'est ce cadre là qui favorise
vous l'avez indiqué notamment au travers
du censi bouvard la nouvelle les
nouvelles constructions plutôt que la
rénovation donc l'ensemble de ces
chantiers sont devant nous et vous
pouvez compter sur mon engagement pour
avancer sur ces questions
merci ronan dantec pour 30 secondes s'il
vous plaît oui je remercie madame la
ministre pour la précision sa réponse et
j'insiste juste effectivement sur
l'importance d'aller très vite sur
l'évaluation du dispositif censi bouvard
ça joue pour les zones de montagne ça
joue pour d'autres zones touristiques
pour la corse ou pour des zones
littorales donc littoral pardon je crois
qu'on a eu une vraie urgence à ce que
cette évaluation puisse faire l'objet
d'un débat
merci je passe la parole à présent
monsieur le président jacques mézard
pour le coupe rds
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
madame la ministre lors de la séance du
13 décembre 2012 vous interveniez dans
le cadre de la proposition de résolution
que j'avais déposé qui a été voté à
l'unanimité par le sénat sur l'égalité
des territoires
vous aviez dit c'est moi qui reviendrait
à cette tribune défendre une loi pour
l'égalité des territoires
onze mois se sont passés et nous sommes
aujourd'hui ici pour parler de la
montagne elle l'aménagement du
territoire la montagne vous le savez la
constater une caractéristique par
rapport aux zones de plaine c'est que ça
monte pour y aller et c'est pas c'est
pas la bretagne avec des voies rapides
d'accès il y a encore dans ce pays des
territoires dans lesquels il est
difficile d'accéder et faire du
développement
quand on n'arrive pas à accéder à
certains territoires comme par exemple
département que j'ai l'honneur de
représenter sa pose de gros problèmes
vous disiez d'ailleurs le 25 octobre
2012 à bastelica aux élus de montagne
qu'il irait un certain nombre de pistes
l'action et en matière de transport vous
disiez qu'il y allait y avoir une
révision du snit qui accorde une claire
priorité au renforcement des
infrastructures et des réseaux de
transport classique
vous disiez même qui aurait un effort
pour l'entretien des voiries municipales
et départementales dont l'écho difficile
à surmonter pour les collectivités
locales
aujourd'hui et pdm y sont en discussion
encore moi je souhaiterais savoir quelle
est la position du gouvernement pour
faciliter l'accès au territoire enclavé
parce que ça c'est un réel problème pour
nous que ce soit par la route bien
évidemment avec les crédits pour les le
pdmi et aussi bien sûr par rapport au
ferroviaire parce que nous savons que
quand ya pas de tgv
nous avons aujourd'hui malheureusement
des lignes sur lesquelles on met
beaucoup plus de temps pour arriver à
destination
kylie à un certain nombre de décennies
pour laquelle est l'objet de la question
merci mais dans le ministre s'il vous
plaît monsieur le sénateur mézard vous
avez raison de rappeler alors mes propos
qui n'était qui était tenu en mon nom
mais qui n'étaient pas les miens investi
les cas mais je vais vous y répondre
précisément pour ce qui est de la loi
égalité des territoires il y à bien et
je les ai signalé en réponse à la
question de monsieur jarlier un titre
égalité des territoires qui figurera
dans la loi de mobilisation des régions
pour la croissance et l'emploi et de
promotion de l'égalité des territoires
cette loi qui est une loi qui sera
présenté par ma collègue marylise
lebranchu intègre volontairement ce
chapitre égalité des territoires pour
justement faire en sorte que la question
des régions et je fais référence à ce
que disait madame david tout à l'heure
ne soient pas prises en considération
indépendamment de cette question de
l'égalité des territoires et de
l'attention à porter aux territoires les
plus fragiles
il en va de même sur la question de
réseau secondaire dont vous avez parlé
ou du réseau existant vous avez pu noter
là je le crois que à l'issue du travail
de révision du snit les arbitrages qui
ont été choisis et qui note un vrai
choix en faveur de l'investissement long
et on était en faveur du réseau existant
notamment du réseaux ferroviaires dont
la remise à niveau était une priorité en
particulier pour la desserte de
territoire qui ne dispose aujourd'hui
pour certains d'entre eux que du train
comme un
l'outil de desserte en transport qui est
suffisamment régulier pour ce qui est du
désenclavement proprement dit il sera
envisagé au titre du volet mobilité des
cpr puisque vous le savez la nouvelle
la nouvelle génération de contrats de
plan est actuellement en discussion elle
a vocation à être contractualisés à
l'été prochain
dans ce cadre là il y aura une
déclinaison territoriale des contrats de
plan état région qui prendront en
considération des situations spécifiques
cette question en fait partie elle sera
donc à l'ordre du jour des discussions
dans l'élaboration de ces contrats de
plan mais je voudrais ici monsieur le
sénateur réaffirmé l'attachement du
gouvernement cette question de l'égalité
des territoires et donc l'ouverture du
débat à l'occasion du titre dans le
cadre du projet de loi pourra donner
lieu évidemment un échange qui comme
vous le savez est toujours un échange
que nous apprécions avec les sénateurs
merci monsieur le président merci madame
la ministre
en fait je ne suis quand même pas
totalement rassuré parce que je crois
que ce n'est pas en créant des au
conseil des comités que l'on trouve des
solutions en fait on ira bâches des
problèmes et nous nous considérons que
ce qu'il faut dans le cadre de l'égalité
des territoires
c'est faire en sorte que l'on mette fin
à la fracture territoriale que vous
dénonciez vous même à juste titre quand
vous ne répondiez voici onze mois et si
je reviens sur la question de l'accès
aux services publics et des pdm ou c'est
parce que c'est véritablement une
nécessité aujourd'hui de permettre un
accès normal à un certain nombre de
territoires qui ont un sentiment
terrible d'abandon et pour lesquels il
faut bien constater que les
gouvernements successifs de toute
sensibilité on tombe on oublié qu'il
était nécessaire dans ce pays de faire
de l'égalité non pas des discours
simplement mais des actes merci
d'apparaître présidence jean claude kern
pour le goût
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je souhaiterais appelez votre
attention sur les conséquences du décret
du 10 mai 2013 définissant les zones
d'application de la majoration de la
taxe sur le foncier non bâti
cette mesure est particulièrement
pénalisante dans un département de
montagne comme la haute savoie et ce
décret concerne les communes où ils
seraient constater un déséquilibre
marqué entre l'offre et la demande de
logements
dans mon département ce sont soixante
communes qui sont touchés autour de
trois agglomérations la mise en oeuvre
de ces mesures induit une majoration
considérable de la tns b pour les
contribuables à partir de 2014
cette majoration peut s'élever à 4000
puis à 8000 euros pour une parcelle de
800 m² pour ne citer qu'un exemple peu
de propriétaires seront en mesure de la
supporter et nombre d'entre eux seront
tout simplement contraints de se défaire
de leur bien c'est de la vente forcée
allant à l'encontre du principe
fondamental du droit de propriété
nombre de mes concitoyens m'ont fait
part de leur colère face à ce qu'ils
considèrent comme une certaine
spoliation et ce d'autant plus que les
terrains concernés pourraient au gré des
modifications dp et lui devenir non
constructive cette mesure provoque aussi
une vague d'inquiétude chez les mères en
effet la liste des zones en tension a
été fixé par les services de l'état sans
aucune concertation avec les élus locaux
pourtant c'est vers eux que nos
compatriotes se retourne pour exprimer
leur indignation et leur exaspération
cette décision administrative se voit
même appliqué dans des communes ne
connaissant aucun problème de logement
certaines étant d'ailleurs relativement
éloignée de l'agglomération soumises à
cette mesure
plusieurs maires là encore m'ont apporté
leur témoignage dans certains cas
l'arrêté du 10 mai et même incompatible
avec les scot et les contraintes issues
des lois montagne et des loi littoral
alors je vous demande donc de m'indiquer
madame la ministre si vous comptez
suspendre l'application de ce décret
afin de mettre en place des mesures
appropriées et supportable par les
contribuables et d'engager une
concertation avec les élus afin
réajuster la liste des communes
concernées merci madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur le décret auquel
vous faites allusion est relatif au
champ d'application de la taxe annuelle
sur les logements vacants
c'est l'article de loi de finances qui
concerne la majoration la taxe sur le
foncier non bâti qui fait référence
effectivement on peut légitimement et
vous le faites assez bien se poser la
question de la pertinence de faire
référence à un décret qui concerne le
les logements vacants sur la majoration
de la taxe sur le foncier non bâti
vous l'avez justement dit effectivement
il ya eu un certain nombre d'inquiétudes
qui ont été soulevées à cette occasion
et je voudrais ici redire l'engagement
du gouvernement à préserver
l'agriculture et les surfaces agricoles
et en particulier l'agriculture
périurbaine et qu'il ne peut pas être
dans notre objectif je le dis puisque
j'étais ici il ya quelques semaines et
tous les parlementaires et ont laissé
tous les sénateurs et les députés
d'ailleurs qui ont participé à ces
débats ont vu l'engagement dans la loi
allure en faveur de la préservation des
terres agricoles et naturels pour lutter
contre leur surconsommation
ce dispositif vise et visera quand il se
rate à plat quand il sera appliqué
puisque vous le savez les communes n'ont
pas pu anticiper cette mesure et s'en
approprier le fonctionnement qui peut
sembler effectivement complexe même s'il
date d'une un vote qui est de mars 2012
qui a été près cette majoration étaient
prévus dès mars 2012
nous avons souhaité faire en sorte que
cette disposition ne s'appliquera pas au
1er janvier 2014 pour que chacun puisse
en mesurer les conséquences et qu'il n'y
ait pas d'effets induits négatif sur les
terrains agricoles cultivées donc je le
redis l'objectif du gouvernement est de
préserver l'agriculture y compris de
proximité y compris l'agriculture
périurbaine mais vise à éviter la
rétention foncière et la spéculation de
terres constructibles de terrains
constructibles qui sont des terrains
vacants et qui sont gardés par leurs
propriétaires en attente de
l'augmentation du prix du foncier c'est
le seul objectif de cette disposition si
elle ne répond pas suffisamment bien cet
objectif à ce stade et qu'elles
soulèvent ces inquiétudes et c'est pour
cela que le gouvernement a décidé
qu'elle ne s'appliquerait pas au 1er
janvier 2014 afin que les choses soient
très claires son objectif est d'éviter
la rétention foncière de terrain
constructible en zone constructible
et absolument pas de fragiliser les
agriculteurs et en particulier
l'agriculture périurbaine les choses
sont je crois très clair monsieur le
sénateur merci monsieur le président car
oui monsieur le président je voudrais
remercier madame la milice de sa réponse
est d'avoir pris la décision de reporter
cette mesure pour prendre en compte les
inquiétudes à la fois des élus est à la
fois des agriculteurs et j'ai bien
essayé de faire en sorte que les effets
soient le moins pervers possible être
protégés notamment les terres agricoles
merci madame la ministre
merci la parole à jean jacques mirassou
pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre il ya maintenant c'est moi
les terribles inondations qui ont sévi
en haute garonne ont dévasté et les
cantons de saint béat de bagnères de
luchon touché gravement ceux de barbazan
de montréjeau et dans une moindre mesure
suivie et saint gaudens l'activité du
président de la république du
gouvernement et des collectivités
territoriales a permis de faire face à
l'urgence en mobilisant des mécanismes
dead tout en débloquant des somme très
conséquente destiné à financer les
travaux prioritaires pour autant ceux
qui restent à réaliser est énorme et ce
dans de multiples registres
c'est du reste ce qui a été exprimé à
l'occasion de sa venue dans le comminges
par la population au préfet de région
qui a été confrontée la population où il
y avait un mélange à la fois de patience
parfois de colère et parfois de désarroi
parce que effectivement là à saint béat
qui est de loin la commune la plus
touchée du massif pyrénéen à luchon
marignac
il s'est rendu compte que beaucoup
d'interrogations subsistent et par
exemple en ce qui concerne le secteur
assurantiel scénarisation que ces gens
là sont en droit d'attendre ne sont pas
arrivés loin s'en faut à la fois chez
les habitants même en étant chez les
commerçants pire certains sinistrés
moment où je parle ont reçu des
courriers émanant de réassurance comme
dans la résilier d'une manière
unilatérale leur contrat d'assurance et
je pense que l'autorité du gouvernement
dans ce registre là doit pouvoir jouer
sa liste des travaux qui peut être
différé le gouvernement est aussi sur
les sites et prom est à l'oeuvre une
coordination rapide à ce qui concerne le
montage financier et en s'affranchissant
si c'est possible certaines règles
habituelles
en ce qui concerne le moyen et le long
terme il s'agit de reconstruire de
retrouver des capacités de développement
local à travers une nouvelle politique
économique permettant aux collectivités
de en quelque sorte se réinventer un
avenir en évidence ce challenge ne
pourront être relevés par les cinq
acteurs locaux et exige vous le
comprendrez mon âme ministres exigent un
engagement sans faille de la part de
l'état c'est à ce prix que la population
sinistrée de reprendre espoir évacuera
les sentiments d'injustice qu'elle
ressent aujourd'hui pour les mêmes et
son territoire vous comprendez dont
madame la ministre
facilement que je m'adresse aujourd'hui
à vous ainsi concernant vos
responsabilités chez vos légumes
territoire dans ce qui est plus une
interpellation les sollicitations qu'une
question prévient merci madame la
ministre s'il vous plaît monsieur le
sénateur mirassou je suis tout à fait
consciente des conséquences terribles de
ces inondations beaucoup des sujets que
vous évoquez ne dépendent pas
directement des attributions du
ministère l'égalité des territoires et
du logement mais je vais tenter de vous
apporter les éléments de réponse que
vous attendez sur l'ensemble des sujets
je veux vous assurer que la mobilisation
de l'état ne faiblit pas depuis le mois
de juin tout d'abord des fonds ont été
mobilisés en urgence pour aider les
collectivités en juillet dernier douze
millions 500 mille francs ont été
délégués dans les trois départements les
plus touchés par les inondations pour
engager les travaux les plus urgents en
parallèle une mission interministérielle
a été rapidement diligentée pour évaluer
le montant des dégâts à l chiffres les
dégâts dans les quatre départements à
113,3 millions d'euros le 22 octobre
dernier le premier ministre a annoncé
que l'état contribuerez aux travaux de
réparation à hauteur de 65 9 millions
d'euros soit un taux d'indemnisation de
58% qui est une prise en charge un
niveau exceptionnel si on compare à
d'autres situations pour ce qui est des
particuliers et des commerçants
l'arrêté de classement en catastrophe
naturelle du 28 juin dernier les
communes de saint béat bagnères de
luchon barbazan et montréjeau sont
incluses dans cet arrêté devrait
permettre une indemnisation plus rapide
j'ai entendu votre point sur la
résiliation unilatérale des contrats qui
est une faculté offerte aux assureurs
mais sur lequel nous allons nous pencher
en discussion un dialogue avec vous je
sais néanmoins que la situation est
urgente et que le mental le manque à
gagner des commerçants met en péril leur
survie pour certains d'entre eux donc
nous faisons tout ce qu'il est en notre
pouvoir pour que c'est intervention
aille le plus rapidement possible pour
la remise en marche de l'économie locale
le camping de saint béat effectivement
été fermés pour des mesures de sécurité
c'est toutefois pour l'instant
simplement une mesure préventive et le
préfet étudie toutes les possibilités
sécurisation du site ou relocalisation
pour ouvre pour permettre une
réouverture au plus vite les services de
l'état sont extrêmement mobilisés sur
place à votre disposition pour vous
accompagner et pour étudier toutes
nouvelles questions notamment ces
questions de résiliation des assurances
qui pourrait naître dans les jours dans
les mois qui viennent très bien chez
mira souvent quelques secondes merci
madame la ministre cette réponse qui
répond à la fois l'urgence en termes de
court terme et mettant ce qui doit se
passer sur le moyen ou le long terme
existerait sur le fait que bon nombre de
mes collègues ont insisté sur la
spécificité de la montagne qu'ils
rencontrent au quotidien quand tout va
bien des difficultés à fortiori quand il
se passe un événement comme si qui s'est
passé en comminges et jude pas une
seconde que la puissance publique
répondra à l'appel est lancé
merci la parole et à monsieur jean
pierre vial pour le groupe ump
oui la ministre très haut débit
constitue une infrastructure au coeur de
l'avenir des territoires et la montagne
constitue une spécificité dans les
handicaps de se répète une nouvelle fois
sous-estimé
après les zones dont blanche et grise le
haut débit n'a pas encore trouvé sa
couleur nous avons bien noté les
engagements du gouvernement à travers le
plan france très haut débit soulignant
que ce service devrait s'appuyer sur
toutes les technologies permettant
d'apporter le plus rapidement possible
meilleur débit à tous nos concitoyens à
travers les différentes technologies
mais nul ne peut contester que le
déploiement d'un tel réseau ne peut être
envisagée sans l'engagement et
l'investissement lourd des collectivités
sans lesquels un déploiement des pas
envisageable en dehors des zones amis et
nécessite que puisse leur être donné un
certain nombre d'assurances temps sur
les moyens financiers techniques et
réglementaires
le premier engagement et bien évidemment
dans ce financier si le gouvernement
doit d'y assumer sa part avec une
contribution de 3,3 milliards de
de subventions encore convient-il que
les territoires puissent avoir
l'assurance que ce handicap de la
montagne sera pris en compte dans les
critères d'accompagnement de l'état
la deuxième question concerne ce
déploiement des technologies nécessaires
qui pourrait faire craindre aux
collectivités de s'engager dans des
investissements lourds avec des risques
importants
il s'agit notamment de l'activation et
du maintien du réseau cuivre sur lequel
beaucoup d'interrogations et des risques
de substitution ou de l'investissement
de fibre optique dont usage pourrait
être évitée par les opérateurs
la troisième garantie est d'ordre
réglementaire et concerne activation des
réseaux fibre optique il ne serait être
laissée à la seule discrétion des
opérateurs parmi les priorités des
collectivités il y avait évidemment les
espaces économiques non les stations
touristiques sont une composante forte
pouvez vous préciser les conditions dans
lesquelles l'opérateur d'un rip peut
intervenir sur le segment entreprises
notamment sur les secteurs où il existe
déjà une oeuvre de gros y compris à
l'intérieur des périmètres des zones
d'intervention conventionnés amis et
préciser les modalités d'attribution des
aides de l'état sur les segments de
marché d'entreprises dans ces zones
géographiques
enfin une bonne part des zones
prioritaires imposées aux opérateurs
pour le déploiement de la couverture 4g
est situé en secteur de montagne est il
possible d'imposer aux opérateurs
titulaires des licences 4g de s'engager
sur une départementalisation de leur
calendrier de couverture notamment pour
l'échéance intermédiaire de 2017 ne
faisant référence qu'à des objectifs
chiffrés au niveau national sens
cartographie précise
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
sénateur d'abord je voudrais m'excuser
je vous ai répondu en francs monsieur
mirassou donc j'ai passé une crise de
jeunesse ou de faiblesse mais c'est bien
deux millions et demi d'euros
donc je le fais très attention notamment
sur les montants qui sont mobilisés par
l'état qui sont très importants en
faveur du programme france très haut
débit qui introduit bien des éléments
prenant en compte la spécificité des
territoires difficiles à équiper comme
les zones de montagne les taux
d'intervention ont en effet été majorée
et les critères de calculs tiennent
compte de la dispersion de l'habitat
comme du taux de ruralité ce qui permet
de coller réellement la réalité des
coûts notamment dans les territoires de
montagne le périmètre des dépenses
éligibles est en outre assez large car
il comprend les réseaux de collecte et
les raccordements finaux ce programme
concerne en priorité le déploiement de
la fibre au plus près de l'usagé ce qui
constitue une première étape
étapes du développement du réseau
optique les équipements d'activation du
réseau cuivre ne sont pas financés par
l'état et la collectivité reste
maîtresse du choix de technologie
qu'elles emploient en ce qui concerne
précisément le basculement du cuivre
vers la fibre
le gouvernement a créé une mission
spécifique dont la conduite a été
confiée à monsieur paul champsaur ancien
président de l'autorité de régulation
des télécommunications sur le cas
particulier que vous citez du segment
marchés entreprises dans les zones amis
vous savez que conformément à la
réglementation européenne les aides de
l'état soutienne les rites que sur les
territoires dépourvus d'initiatives
privées il faut absolument rentrer dans
ce cadre quoique nous en pensions enfin
sur la question de la 4g
les obligations des opérateurs sont bien
départementalisée puisque le taux de
couverture devra être d'être devra être
de 99,6 % de la population nationale à
2027 et au moins de 90% de la population
de chaque département français à 2024 et
95% en 2027 il ya bien donc un objectif
départementalisée en outre
l'accélération de ce déploiement est
envisageable sur tel ou tel territoire
suivant des modalités identifié entre
opérateurs et collectivités je verrai ce
que je veillerai à ce que cette
mobilisation soit mené en particulier
dans les territoires ruraux où le
déploiement de la 4g pour des usages
fixe ou mobile est encore plus important
et urgent merci monsieur vial oui madame
la ministre merci pour vos réponses
extrêmement précises notamment sur le
premier point en ce qui concerne l'aide
de l'état avec un taux majoré que j'ai
bien noté sur la situation du cuivre
j'ai noté effectivement la mission
donner à monsieur champsaur
il s'agit madame le ministre d'une
question tout à fait importante car bien
évidemment en fonction des décisions qui
seront prises
et vous savez les inquiétudes que les
élus peuvent avoir compte tenu de ce qui
s'est dit à ce sujet il s'agit d'un
élément non négligeable dans le choix de
dd schéma mis en place par les
collectivités
en ce qui concerne les zones amis les
zones entreprises dans les zones
couvertes les allemands on a mis un
ministre j'insiste sur ce point il est
quand même pour le moins paradoxal que
les apple et l'opérateur puisse déclarer
préempté un territoire et que dans ce
territoire y est les zones économiques
qui constitue quand même une priorité et
sur lesquelles disent les collectivités
très peu de garanties pour ne pas dire
aucune merci beaucoup merci monsieur
pierre bernard émond pour la réunion des
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe
madame la ministre la plus flagrante des
inégalités de territoire c'est celle qui
naît de l'enclavement l'exemple du
département des hautes-alpes est très
significatif à cet égard qu'il s'agisse
du projet de tunnel ferroviaire franco
italien sous le col du montgenèvre au de
l'autoroute a51 dernier chaînon manquant
autoroutier a réalisé entre grenoble et
gap sur les itinéraires genève marseille
et lyon nice ce n'est qu'une longue
histoire de promesses non tenues et
d'espoirs déçus décidé en 1987 annulé
par monsieur gayssot réinscrit par son
successeur
elle a fait l'objet d'un débat public
favorable en 2004 promise par le
candidat hollande elle a été reportée
par la commission dureront au delà de
2050 quand on se moque des populations à
ce point il ne faut pas s'étonner
qu'elle se révolte et que les bonnets
rouges fleurissent sur notre territoire
en effet vous avez ignoré lac ce gap
grenoble dans le schéma des
infrastructures de transport mais vous
n'avez pas oublié la route actuelle la
route napoléon qui est à peu près dans
l'état où la laisser l'empereur pour la
mise en place de l'écotaxe ce projet
autoroutier conforme à l'article 10 du
grenelle 1 devait générer 2000 vrais
emplois par an pendant six ans et ils
pouvaient être financée entièrement par
le secteur privé
en acceptant de longue durée de
concession plutôt que d'inciter les
entreprises et les collectivités à créer
de faux emplois pour redresser la courbe
du chômage avant la fin de l'année
n'eût-il pas été préférable de susciter
des investissements d'avenir tel que
celui ci
mais je ne viens pas demander une
nouvelle fois au gouvernement de tenir
ses engagements
je lui propose de s'alléger de ce
dossier en le décentralisant auprès d'un
groupement de quatre départements les
plus concernés l'isère la drôme les
hautes-alpes et les alpes de haute
provence
dont les présidents donc 300 socialistes
sont tous très favorable à cette
réalisation
l'égalité des territoires par la
décentralisation par l'investissement et
par la création d'emplois
n'est ce pas un beau programme madame la
ministre merci madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur l'égalité des
territoires est un beau programme
vous avez raison et c'est celui du
gouvernement et j'en suis très heureuse
mais le projet à 51 que vous évoquez
dans votre question est très ancien il
consisterait à réaliser un barreau
autoroutier entre le col du fau et la
sauce comme l'indiqué le rapport du rond
que vous avez mentionné qui a été remis
en juin dernier au premier ministre ce
projet controversé quant à ces enjeux
d'une part il soulève de nombreuses
difficultés au plan technique mais aussi
environnementales puisqu'il traverse des
espaces remarquables et protégés
les zones des zones natura 2000 et le
parc national des écrins
d'autre part la question du financement
est également très compliqué puisque son
coût est chiffré environ deux milliards
et demi d'euros ce qui supposerait
compte non tenu des prévisions de trafic
un besoin concours plus pire public de
près de 2 milliards d'euros pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons et comme vous
le savez il n'a pas été retenu dans les
priorités du dit rapport l'état ne
participera donc pas au financement
d'une telle opération quelle que soit la
maîtrise d'ouvragés proposés par
ailleurs seul l'état la possibilité de
recourir à des concessions pour la
réalisation d'infrastructures
autoroutières
il ne semble donc pas envisageable pour
un syndicat intercommunal de réaliser
une telle infrastructure sous forme
concédé en revanche les perspectives
sont ouvertes dans le cas des cpr pour
travailler à la modernisation de la rn
85 en vous disant simplement sous forme
de clin d'oeil que je ne crois pas que
le bitume existait au temps de napoléon
et que donc il est peu juste de dire que
l'état était que l'état de cette route
est la même que celle de l'époque de
napoléon qui pourrait aussi constituer
une piste de solution à la difficulté
d'enclavement je voudrais dire à ce
stade que je ne méconnais pas pour
autant les enjeux désenclavement gelé
indiqué en réponse notamment la question
du présent mais art dont souffrent
certains territoires de montagne et
certaines zones des alpes du sud
mais je crois qu'il faut penser le
désenclavement pas uniquement du point
de vue la desserte routière
mais dans la perspective d'une stratégie
globale de mobilité
nous y travaillons
notamment pour évaluer la possibilité et
la mise en oeuvre effective d'une
desserte de l'ensemble des communes de
france par des systèmes de mobilité y
compris à la demande qui serait gérée
dans le cadre d'une mission de service
public qui permettrait à l'ensemble des
habitants de notre pays de ne pas
souffrir de cet enclavement que vous
n'êtes souligné merci madame la ministre
monsieur pierre bien n'a vraiment madame
la ministre je ne vous en veux pas de
répercuter dans cet hémicycle les notes
qui vous ont été transmises par votre
administration et qui sont en partie
fausse car il n'y a aucune zone natura
2000 sur le tracé proprement dit de
cette autoroute
je voudrais simplement vous faire une
invitation madame la ministre
venez voir de quoi il s'agit venez faire
l'autre la route entre grenoble et gap
voyez exactement ce qu'il en est et puis
pour terminer je vous indique que tout à
l'heure je vais rejoindre mon
département je vais rejoindre gap
je vais partir à 17h19 de la gare de
lyon et je serai à 23h30 à mon domicile
merci madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi relatif à
l'économie sociale et solidaire
voilà pour les questions cribles
consacré à la montagne à 16h15 ne
manquez pas le discours de françois
hollande qui inaugure les commémorations
consacrée au centenaire de la première
guerre mondiale on y reviendra
d'ailleurs dans 24heures sénat à 19
heures avec delphine girard très bonne
après midi sur les chaînes
parlementaires
en